okay so this episode is the blue demon
and I'm gonna sound like a real dumbass
um I'm assuming that if you're watching
this you would have seen the episode and
the blue demon is this masked character
really athletic or really good with uh
you know a hand hand combat and weapons
and stuff at first not the whole way
through but at first I thought maybe it
was going to be the old lady the lady
that gives the Cure's with the frozen
frogs is that I know how stupid that
sounds but yeah it's the only other
character they introduced so I thought
maybe is gonna be her and you know then
you see the person's really athletic I'm
like well maybe that's gonna be the
message you know like oh you can't you
know judge a book by it's cover and old
people can eat just as if let it can
gold people uh
and then as you see more and more of the
body its are like yeah that's that's
probably not her and the answer was
actually unbelievably obvious but uh
yeah so that's my dumb mistake that I
made if I share it with you
um but yeah with that said Blue Demon
this is another really strong episode
you got um uh yet Sokka
and a Katara are both sick and I like
that I like that actually carries over
from the last episode because it always
seems to be the thing like you know
superheroes and stuff they go through
all this stuff and there's never any
consequences or repercussions of what
happened physically in the last one I
like even something as small as just
getting sick from the rain I really like
that I like that they type that in so
cleverly um and some good lines from a
second as I like the hallucinations and
stuff are really good um I also like how
you don't we finally see what Momo hears
you know what the animals here cuz it is
like well how much do these animals
understand and you see from his point of
view it's actually very little to the
point where they just wanted to go get
water and he keeps bringing back all
these various things that they probably
sell for water but he never actually
brings water so what can you do uh but
that's not the focus the focus is uh you
got uh Aang is fighting off the this
now this general that's been promoted I
forget his name that the Malfoy guy um
you know so he's promoted and he gets
these archers are like world-class
archers they make you know Legolas look
like a leg of lamb I mean it's just like
they're really good and they managed to
capture the avatar they're so good they
can capture a kid with arrows without
killing him uh and I like the fact they
gave an explanation I really like this
because in so many of these shows of
course the villain can't kill the hero
because you need the hero alive and why
do they keep them alive and they always
have to make up these excuses this is a
good excuse they say if we kill you
you'll just be reincarnated as someone
else see you know it that's how it works
so we're actually gonna keep you alive
not only as long as possible but as
painfully as possible that makes sense
so I that's a very clever way around
especially in the kid show why you can't
kill this character I thought that was
very smart um but uh but obviously you
get this um that this blue demon
character it comes in the saves egg get
him out of there I'm still some of these
wind bending powers like I don't know
how it's like he's how can anyone
restrain this kid when you see half the
stuff he does I mean he just goes and
blows this guy across the room it's like
how how can anyone restrain this kid I I
don't know whatever you put him in it's
like he can probably get out of it but
again at the epoch uh so this blue demon
comes along get them out of there
doesn't speak wears a mask and most of
it is just this long well done fight
scene of them escaping it that remind me
a lot of Disney's a Robin Hood like how
good that climax was how just everything
is trying to get it it's just like you
know one person will to this time you
know trying to get out of this place and
every time they're about to make it
something else stops them a million
other guys are coming in and they gotta
get away from then again think on their
feet it's a very exciting good action
sequence I really like those sequences
where just everything is out to get the
hero and somehow they keep avoiding it
and they but they don't do with ease
it's like you can see the panic and get
your heart going and stuff so it's it's
real
be really good and then it gets
especially interesting when you know the
the general says you know I kill the
blue guy but don't kill the Avatar we
need him alive
and then the blue guy he takes out the
swords and holds it up to Aang's neck
and even Aang is like oh like he
could kill me um and you know that
ushers their escape
I get that very very smart especially
when you find out you know who it is
which again I think I give away is Zuko
obviously um and it's interesting
because we know obviously why he's doing
it he's doing it so he can get his honor
bags and he can return the avatar you
can get the glory
we found the general is pretty much
doing it for the same reason uh you know
he wants the glory as well and I think
both the main difference I think the
general knows the avatar is powerful but
I think he still sees because he's a kid
alright that this is still managed but
like I can do this it's it's a kid but
we can do this uh and I like a Zuko like
he underestimate him once and now he's
like never again I will not ever do that
again so I like there's a little bit of
a variation with the two villains there
um and the the design of this place as
always is really good good shadows in
this one good harsh heavy shadows uh but
you can still make it out it's not so
bad that you know you're doing what's
going out what you can still make it out
and it just makes the scenes so much
more menacing and so much more intense
um so the other thing that I say is
really strong in this one that again
sort of continuing over from the last
episode is that connection between Aang
and Zuko that there is very much this
connection and now they're starting to
see it they're starting to sort of
realize it as well um I think Aang puts
it here because he realizes that Zuko is
doing this now for himself to get back
something he really needs or he really
values and Aang knows that he's
essentially doing what he's doing for
the same reason uh and he puts it
together you know there's a scene where
he's sitting with
Zuko Zuko's waking up he still by his
side you know probably protecting him
making sure nobody comes after him and
you know says you know well what if in
another life you know we could have been
friends we could have been this you know
or whatever yeah touch cliche but I mean
warranted it's a warranted speech
um and Zuko just sort of look Sam and
just like with one blow it's like she
often tries to kill I just a really
great scene but you can again just by
seeing Zuko trying to sleep that night
you can see that he knows it too that
they're actually more similar than than
they realize um and it's just this is
the situation they're in and they just
they got a deal with it and and I like
that you can see Aang hit you know
realizes that too when he goes well when
he goes back to sock on Katara you know
that a he's her rolling - and they say
did you make a friend and no you know
and there's and and you can feel a
sadness in both of them that you know a
maybe another circumstance maybe like we
could have been like really really good
friends or something but there's this is
the circumstance that is and at least
for now there's no changing it and
that's why I got out but not that
there's never going to be a change for
it but that the situation now is that it
can't happen and they both acknowledge
that um so again a real strong Leverett
real good one and even though the
majority of it is action I think when
you find out who it is
uh and how strongly they're actually you
know that Zuko is not only fighting to
get this kid out so he can claim him but
also that they are working together um I
think the action the longer action It
Again is justified I think it actually
really works and it's kind of needed
because you need to see them working
together even though he's got the face
covered so again very a very good
episode you know my favorite ones are
obviously the ones who really continue
the story and really look into the
characters
and let them sort of lead the story so
another real strong one
about all I can say about and I'll see
the next one